if it's levy to see here at the premier
penny dreadful tonight know your
characters a very enigmatic woman isn't
she with that thousand-yard stir that
she's got how did you go about
perfecting that and what did you most
enjoy about throwing her Wow I think
she's a very very cool character they're
very complex and kind of an
individualist hungry for life wanting to
explore everything at a time when women
were very very repressed and she's just
a very you know strong woman she decide
you know she she she's her own woman and
she's um she's one of the most difficult
roles and had to face a lot lots of lots
of homework lots of challenges she's a
very fearless character isn't she how
fearless a year in real life it's funny
that you're asking that I think a lots
of actors are very scared in real life
and that's why we we are actors we can
play people who are so brave and we can
do crazy things and and yet Vanessa is
she's been through hell and she's kind
of built this armor in order to survive
and she's you can you discover the
cracks episode after episode there's
there's a long journey and she's not
just one mysterious woman you understand
why she's behaving this way in the first
episode now as I said she's a mysterious
character with copper see she say going
to learn more about it to go long how
much fun is that views an actress kind
of peeling back those layers I'm
revealing them to the audience that's
the best thing and that's a good thing
about TV at the same time because you
have time to explore character and and
to show so many colors so yeah you
I think yeah it takes a little while for
I think for B for the audience to
understand Vanessa and then you
I think you will identify with her and
understand her paying and past yeah
also of course looking forward to very
much to seeing here in the sequel to
SimCity what did you enjoy most about
being part of that particular movie and
what can audiences look forward to from
your role in the film well I haven't
seen Sin City yet but it's it's a I'm
playing Ava Lord the dame to kill for
she is she's like the archetype of the
femme fatale she is actually very funny
very sharp she's a real [ __ ] yeah she
is it's great I mean you know that this
style of Sin City is so iconic and then
cold and proud to be part of this
venture levy sweetie Ava thanks so much
for your time
you